consumer behavior is constantly changing
true at the onset of the pandemic and
it's all the more true today even with
inflation One retail expert says this
holiday season is the year of the
consumer to take a look what
throughout much of 2020 and 2021 the
covet pandemic was a top driver of
consumer behavior that shifted in a
major way for 2022. this year we've seen
one of the top forces shaping our
day-to-day lives the current economic
climate and retailers having to entice
consumers the consumer has unprecedented
power this holiday season Deborah
weinswig is the CEO and founder of
coresight research she helps
corporations understand Global retail
and emerging technology Trends since the
pandemic more businesses have sought out
this type of research what we're seeing
for the first time I will say in my
career is a lot of experimentation by
retailers and Brands so they're really
trying a lot of new things
and the consumer is going to be the
winner retail traffic is up year upon
year versus 2019. consumers have
returned to Brick and Mortar shops
winesweig says this year retailers are
price beating not just price matching
sometimes offering reductions to
customers in store when asked inventory
that was trapped in factories and
containers has all slid into the retail
ecosystem which means you've got a lot
of inventory from All Seasons to choose
from holiday deals started in October
earlier than ever before retailers are
also offering new ways to shop with live
streaming using their store associates
to engage with the product and the brand
and this year a big push for previously
love merchandise we're seeing a big
movement in more refurbed and consumer
electronics
in 2020 and 2021 a huge uptick right in
demand for furniture and workout
equipment creating a lot of excess
inventory on everything that was ordered
so expect some good deals on those items
this year